you know it's even worse that though
when a guy like that dies when you're
trying to [ __ ] broadcast and some
[ __ ] woman is talking in your ear
nothing is worse that there are you are
trying to do something and some [ __ ]
is yammering in your ear Jimmy
no I'm talking about wait what are we
doing for Labor Day Travis Travis what
do we what do we what do we have on our
people giving him [ __ ] about this I love
him I mean he doesn't come across well
he comes across [ __ ] great I never
cared about lawrence O'Donnell he's now
my favorite broadcaster like you're not
sitting there looking at the lawrence
O'Donnell tape going oh why would
somebody leaked the tape of this guy
that's so that's kind of [ __ ] up he
seems like a good dude no I'm watching
this and I'm going I know they're
leaking it to make him seem like a dick
and watching this build I'm like he's a
hundred percent right well you can't you
can't you can't treat the people around
you like complete subhuman pieces of
[ __ ] yes you're the guy on cam no but
what you can do is when you're trying to
do something and people are talking in
your ear he's at first he's being like
there's this too much talking in my ear
in the controller basically he's trying
to do some kind of like I guess a you
know I don't know what talk to me SOT
means sot i don't know it's lingo yeah
it's it's some type of thing but he's
trying to do like this read into camera
for the story and someone is just
talking in his ear so he's getting
annoyed like he's right he's [ __ ]
broadcasting and somebody is yapping in
his ear slight i know it happens a lot
it's not mean sound on tape sound
nothing so it's happening or it's a he
keeps trying to do it just watch it we
can't watch the whole eight minute tape
but watch a minute so this is the build
i build is phenomenal but he is building
he's not just yelling this went down on
an august 29th they said this is all
from one show and somebody from from
MSNBC just leaked it yesterday yesterday
afternoon and it kind of went everywhere
immediately right there there were
probably moments on the tape where I
thought he might be overdoing it a
little bit I thought that you get
completely reasonable
you could probably calm down a little
bit you know what I mean there's
probably a lot of people there that hate
his guts how about one goes and this
would be this would be evidence as to
why like if somebody came to me and said
yeah I work for Lawrence O'Donnell aye
hate that guy I wouldn't be like that's
weird what you hate him for I would say
what did you do wrong to upset the great
Lawrence O'Donnell if it's a live show
which I think this was that's got to be
frustrating
I guess just read the [ __ ] news and
go home read the [ __ ] thing I don't
have to remember it just read it off the
deal and then go home it's not like you
know the new he's frustrated but at this
point the way the cable news works he
can't afford to be going off on people
like just okay lawrence O'Donnell is
kind of a dick when there's people in
his ear so let's just replace him and
find somebody who's cool with people and
they're you know yeah it's difficult to
talk when somebody's yammering in your
it is when you gotta read something like
if I need to talk to if I need to say
something to Jim I make sure that I wait
for him to not be talking because I know
that it's going to throw you off it's
it's difficult awk about Labor Day oh
he's a hundred percent if he would have
walked in there if they would've said
lawrence O'Donnell was reprimanded for
pushing a woman's head through glass but
what did she do it she was yapping about
Labor Day all your team Lawrence
O'Donnell
I also think it's okay sometimes for
things to be difficult like yeah you
know you read the news for a living like
it's okay if every now and then you have
to do something that's not just easy
let's watch the build a little bit cuz
he's not every media he's not being a
dick immediately Thank You Rachel okay
smile
Trump visited Texas but he forgot to
bring any empathy with him but he did
bring a hat a hat that is for sale and
was he joking or serious there was that
part of the real reader now yeah this is
long yeah but it was him like
criticizing Trump yeah I don't know why
am I losing this see I didn't know
applause I didn't know if that was like
a real but MSNBC actually have a
newscasters say that yeah he I mean he's
the most like one of the most liberal
guys on TV no no I know but I mean I
didn't realize that they did well I
guess the way editorializing yeah yeah
oh yeah because he sells all of his hats
on his website right yeah no no I know
so he had a new hat
I just loved it like he's going this is
a story about how Donald Trump is a jerk
and let's go to the tape hey you [ __ ]
[ __ ] can you not get anything
right around here well you know he's
100% right so far he wants this is a
professional man right all right that's
fact like someone's pressing buttons and
turning my sound off that's Cowell who
was who's asking for a Labor Day one day
okay I must have amend my sense he was
he is immediately annoyed me as soon as
he hears a voice in his ear his bottom
jaw just gets clenched yeah yeah you
have to see the visual will tweet up the
video to his bottom jaw just completely
tighten this up like he's gonna [ __ ]
somebody up and he's going who is
pushing Park needs in my ear he's right
okay I had more about Lawrence go ahead
Lawrence just glaring he's cranky he's
[ __ ] tie have some coffee pal he's
fine now
someone in that control room is out of
control yes he's not happy no not happy
he's very upset to you but just think
about that like working for a guy like
that who you're like okay it gets okay
when he's live like you're just you just
you live for the moments when he's
actually on the air because you know as
soon as he throws to tape its somebody's
ass you know like as soon as he throws
to tape he's gonna have the clenched jaw
he's gonna be scowling he's gonna be
looking to kill somebody and you're like
please just go back live please just go
back live I like when he's like
pretending to be pretending to be a good
guy yeah like oh well I'm just I'm just
looking out for the people because our
president isn't and I think it's a it's
a valuable thing for Americans to watch
Americans back and let's look at this
list clip from Donald Trump we should
get that who is doing that right now
he's completely right I'm still team
Lawrence no John even after realizing
the error of thinking that he took a
while to build I was talking in my ear
I'm still team Lauren we hate that
out-of-control clip from when Anthony
[ __ ] up in here yeah oh my god some of
the control him is out of control I mean
the control room is out of control
that's right should I say that
one for the air you get to play on words
now I get that good stuff gone now in
control he really is getting cranky fats
this god damn it god bless him he just
freaks out here's why they're still
talking in his ear they're still talking
in his ear he puts his hands up which
it's you know my favorite part about
this whole thing is that that one tiny
second is the screen grab that
everybody's using for this watch
lawrence O'Donnell become a crazy man
and it's the one second where he puts
his hands up and it's like he's clawing
the air I can't believe that there's a
mystery woman still it is easier yeah
he's so right he's just he gets very
piecey very exasperated okay so go back
just a little bit
because I like when he goes no go back
before that cuz I like when he goes like
[ __ ] and then he goes goddamnit and then
he spazzes out and then he gets right to
the news okay that's a profession he is
hot under the collar there someone
please make a me matter that does gotta
be it would it be a gif damn it I'm old
we could meet me on the president went
to Texas today and as political reporter
here hey let me criticize this president
supercut ever get out of my head they're
still talking to me about God knows what
like Lawrence relax you know relax take
the take your earpiece out and just read
what's on the blue paper you know
there's it's also in front of you on the
screen read the read the screen and take
the earpiece out if you have to it would
be great if there was actually nobody
talking to him and he's just a crazy
person that would know how hard was it
for his staff to not be cracking up
all he's doing this the price scared of
him I'd be ducking under the table one
of the reasons I can get a promotion if
I do this little action it would be
impossible to not laugh at this even if
you're scared of him like just looking
for a corner to go hide in so you can
chuckle you don't many times this tape
was passed around before it was like
guarantee it was passed for yeah
guaranteed it's just the best of
lawrence O'Donnell and you can never
trace places of death video
yes copies of copies of copies and you
can't trace it cuz digitally this just
once someone has it everyone's got it
it's out there yep I guess I see an inch
of rain or get near a flooded street and
born in horrific disaster and tragedy
and into that tragedy today step two the
President of the United States there's
insanity in the control he's pissed he's
he said again he can't believe this is
happening man did the hands thing I love
to that he's like the rage so angry what
happened is it is it like what a person
gets into a position of power no it's
when you can't believe there's such
order incompetence no it's it's it's not
the POW it's the fact that I'm in his
life when he would get that angry and
people would be like [ __ ] you and just
punch him you know baby but I mean the
bottom line is he has like an on-air job
to do
right and what's happening to him at
this moment is so avoidable and it's
somebody who's [ __ ] not doing their
job you push the wrong button and it's
like it's but he supposed rest it the
first time it was annoyed and it's
continuing to happen so whoever he's
talking to is not fixing the problem in
the control room like these people all
know there's a problem and this [ __ ]
[ __ ] is still talking about Labor Day
does this make you appreciate it to be
on radio where if Stefan is on this show
specifically if something's going wrong
you can you could just address it that's
it's it's such a relief to be able to
that's the beauty of stand-up overacting
or radio over TV is you can address when
things are the wheels are coming off of
your frustrated you can talk about it
and a lot of times you can bring the
person
and call them out and get something out
of it you can't do that what he's doing
so he just has to [ __ ] swallow it and
plow if we had to plow through and you
know and Sam and I were talking and then
talk about this [ __ ] off the air this
would be horrible yeah let's just man
and and it's little things to cuz
there's such perfectionist like let's
say Anthony when Anthony was a second
lane on that sound bite for us no big
deal it happens it's what I'm fun of
them well yet make fun of them if we
have to or don't even knowledge it
whatever like it doesn't matter but if
this were like cable news
that's right who's the second lane I'm
just over there yeah okay we're go back
on okay and the president tonight was
goddamnit
Anthony you're [ __ ] me up and it's
like it's like they feel like they've
this rage bills in them cuz O'Reilly was
this same rageful guy yeah this rage
fills in them where they feel like the
entire staff around them is you're just
all here to [ __ ] me aren't you he's
really upset he is he's personally a
thin lips and he is livid livid he's a
block headed man he's a he's an angry
blockhead busy he's a block headed
thin-lipped a man if you think the
president's language was a little too
celebratory about the sudden fame that
can happen to people during hurricane
coverage a Fame no one should welcome if
you think the president's language miss
closer and closer to the President
himself one of the deaths in vice versa
nor every time he stops a sentence like
it like just there you can see it like
in the middle of a sentence where
there's a pause that's a split second
too long between two words I'm assuming
there's some lady going so what are we
doing for lane have a but I don't know
if I'm gonna cook you want to cook we're
talking about what the network's doing
but how much better would it be if it
was just a girl a lady trying to make
plans for Labor Day is everybody from
the station getting together with some
annoying [ __ ] he's sitting there going
like yeah the president was celebratory
in Texas no we're not inviting Lawrence
are we I would I would read that would
really make me happy well you mean
you're not inviting me from his Police
Sergeant Steve Peres who had been
missing since Sunday morning
you have insanity in my earpiece talking
through his clenched teeth don't don't
leave it there
don't leave it this is leaving Titus
it's somebody talking on our lines don't
try to fix it you're not gonna be able
to fit yeah the guy tries to touch him
some I am completely on his side you
always think like how do how do a KERS
get caught saying nasty things on
microphones but then you realize that
like it's all taping lawrence O'Donnell
ten seconds before he goes on live TV is
going oh [ __ ] god damn it
so the president yeah and they're all
the tapes just rolls of course it's a
digital now that just rolls
yeah do you think it's on film where
they're like you know I don't know it's
gonna cost us a lot of money to keep it
know everything they might they probably
just tape the studio 24 hours a day
because who cares anything anybody walks
in there yeah do a show whatever yeah so
pissed President Trump did not mention
sergeant Paris today and he has not
tweeted about people are in shelters
across there is something great about
this clip here's where it's like you're
realizing that even when like these
anchors try to be as sincere as possible
right he's trying to be sincere and talk
about this system yes sergeant
yeah and Trump he doesn't care about any
of this stuff he doesn't care about the
hurricane and care of a Trump doesn't
care about sergeant Perez all he cares
about is this goddamn woman in his ears
yeah that's what's in his head yeah he's
faking the sincerity he is absolutely
and I hate that cuz I'm a hurricane guy
you're a hurricane go would you support
hurricanes that was me being sincere
that's good right I see it in your eyes
Travis is talking to you in your ears
right now isn't he yes he is he's saying
do you hate him and I'm going yes to you
are you doing about lawrence O'Donnell
right no not talk about you either
[Laughter]
now hit playboy Houston's mayor so this
afternoon every time we go to a soft
there's a woman talking in my ear about
thing that has nothing to do with what
we're doing here now like [ __ ] you yes
yeah we have we know we heard you well
we heard you once you get all pissy
about it Lawrence hey Larry
just do your job read what's on the
teleprompter layer and shut up you can't
take your piece out he feels
disrespected stop talking on the goddamn
thing he's right he doesn't wanna take
his earpiece out because why should he
have to not do his job right because
some unprofessional [ __ ] [ __ ]
doesn't know what they're doing
just if he went literally would've
picked up a [ __ ] a paperweight and
smashed someone's teeth in I'd still be
on his side just take the path of least
resistance on this one take the earpiece
out and let some chubby guy count you
down behind camera and just read what's
on the screen sure and then walk it he
should walk into that control room and
literally begin swinging something he
probably did I hope so if you look at
his energy that does strike you as the
type of energy that would do that I hope
so would it be great if the way Fox News
had sex scandals everywhere that all
their anchors were like trying to [ __ ]
the the the correspondents and stuff
that at MSNBC all the anchors were
horribly violent people that they kept
going in and just beating their staff
unmercifully like Rachel Maddow was just
kicking the [ __ ] out of staffers I love
a good I love a good anchor meltdown
it's the best cuz he gets even worse
here fellows national correspondent for
the Atlantic and the former speechwriter
for President Jimmy Carter on Obama
he's an MSNBC political she's kind of
scowling at the camera she's a mean guy
thin lips he's not people go like oh you
know this is my dream come true I've
always wanted to be a news anchor he is
not happy to be a newsie nobody's just
it's not like you don't have that kind
of anger in you ready to just run leash
if you're a happy guy he's not a guy
who's like you know what this is what
I've always wanted to do and I'm here
and I'm reading the news for a living
he's not happy he goes to bed unhappy
he's not sure of his job he's whatever
is stressing him out he is stressed all
the time he's not a happy guy
he's not living his dream no there's
still team Lawrence I know you're out
right now you're still team Lawrence 90%
all right fellows and Josh earnest thank
you both for joining us tonight really
appreciate it
he doesn't appreciate anything coming up
is Donald Trump going to be called to
testify to Congress Michael Isikoff has
the latest on that sir he's got to say
stop the hammer and then adopt the
hammering out there who's got a hammer
where is it where's the hammer is it on
me I go up on the other floor somebody
go up there and stop the hammering
where's the guard the hammering I don't
think he's mad about the hammering he's
trying to do his job
[ __ ] someone's hammering he's right I
don't think it's the hammering that's
got to upset he's been he's had a bad
night I think there's other things in
his life that he's taking it out on the
hammer I don't think so I think that
when your honor you he has a schedule to
keep and someone is hammering so he's
broadcasting that's not professional
someone's hammering he wants him to go
upstairs downstairs side to side
whatever you have to do to stop that
hammering he's completely justified to
not want hammering while he's parties
try to broadcast and there's somebody
hammering there's craziness in the as I
call it out of control room and then the
guys hammering right above me oh they're
[ __ ] with me tonight he's completely
right to not want some [ __ ] [ __ ]
yammering about Labor Day and some
[ __ ] hammering what could the guy be
hammering what are you doing in a
television studio hammering while the
man is broadcasting they don't know
maybe they didn't sound perfect the
studio well because they were that's
possible they don't know if he's
upstairs downstairs so I decide they
don't know where this guy is he there
are probably more polite ways that he
could have handled that no nope nope
this is totally right I'm gonna start
yelling it uh
the guys who work here like that okay
yeah that's up to you
I'm fine yeah so I started just being
like what the [ __ ] are you doing over
there and that just like venomous yeah
you'd be like good I'll get you back
thanks man okay cool cool all right get
ready for Anthony right
I'll go down to the goddamn floor myself
and stop and keep the goddamn commercial
break going all [ __ ] Phil Griffin I
don't care who the [ __ ] you have to call
stop the hammering hashtag it before
interns got to give him papers I feel so
bad for sure I ran right off there's a
couple times in that video where the
girl comes on and has to drop his papers
off in front of him and she is petrified
even though it's not her fault no but
she just doesn't want to be around that
energy do you think eating lawrence
O'Donnell would have gone down and just
grab somebody's hammer and just beat him
to death with depend on the size of the
person yeah hopefully it's the same
woman yapping in his ear that was
hammering so he could just bash our
brains in with it and [ __ ] get it all
out of the way lawrence O'Donnell just
comes back on television for his
send-off and he's got just blood all
over his face like Patrick Bateman in
American Psycho music that's been the
news this evening week a hammer
wouldn't you love to have you out a hack
into that and like do the talking while
he's like trying to like just to [ __ ]
talk about something mindless in his ear
I would you I thought about that how
great that would be how amazing it would
be to just be in his earpiece to have
some terrible conversation not taunting
him to no no as if you don't even know
it's on yeah my god you watch you watch
Walking Dead last night it was a rerun
was that a rerun yeah and he's just
losing his mind
each other meatloaf yeah you once you
figure out that that bothers him as much
as it does Oh what I want to take
advantage of it
I really would you know what size waist
are you I'm a 31 but you know it's funny
I was a 32 for quite a while how'd you
get the how'd you get that extra number
our hard work the [ __ ] is going on I
would love to see him I wanted I wish I
could see what happened after this like
I would love to see he musta spaz the
[ __ ] out you need to smash things in his
office I don't know what the resolution
was like did he realize that it was
something that was no one's on his
floors fault okay I'm sorry I apologize
yeah like maybe it wasn't in control
maybe there was a [ __ ] maybe it was a
signal like once in a while you pick up
a radio signal you're not supposed to
pick up maybe had nothing to do with the
control and they could stop it here's
was dangerous though if he apologized he
didn't mean the apology he just
swallowed all that anger and guess what
it's all
come out again he just swallowed it down
and the next time oh is it gonna hurt
stop the hammering that's like well what
was it what was the tagline for that
show heroes on NBC find the girl or
something like that
save the girl we'll save the girl I'll
save the world save the girl stop the
hammering someone from Oklahoma City is
saying that he's 100% right unless she's
quoting Caleb I don't know what she's
saying
caleb is her name I think so hello okay
okay okay they spelled a Caleb Caleb we
thought you were like a rapper
as a former on-air talent and television
director I'm getting curious you were on
the air did you ever freak out on
anybody like this oh I never freak down
anybody out my IFB out and around told
the floor directors what should be doing
now you tell the lazy ass [ __ ] head
set off if she's not talking directly to
me I mean we've all been there like I've
told ongoing
I've told my story is about yeah getting
angry and like freaking out on like
people serving popcorn and stuff like
you sometimes you get angry when you see
incompetence and you just lose control
yeah we all do it but especially when
you're actually doing your job it's even
worse yeah when you're trying to do your
job all right thanks for the call I
appreciate but but you do have to at
some point if the people are working for
you you have to at least treat them like
human beings but again I don't know how
long this was going on or this is when
it started but they're not working for
him they're working for the network and
they're not doing their jobs it's not
like they're just they're just not doing
what they're supposed to do someone is
not stopping people from talking in his
ear and he's right to not want that
while he's broadcasting like he's got a
job to do and they're [ __ ] him up so
it sounds like a dick thing to do he's
got that John nice and clench but it's
unnecessary like his job is being [ __ ]
with unnecessarily just because someone
doesn't know what they're doing and it's
like it's such an avoidable problem he's
probably not a great guy to get into a
fight with at home he might be a total
[ __ ] I don't know but
I would imagine yes in this particular
thing I see him as being correct and you
might hear a little more you go zero to
100 real oh no someone is saying that
I'm is against what I'm saying so I will
take that call in fairness yes John in
Jersey hello yea or nay John hey he says
there's a buffoon if you're going to put
people on hold can we make sure that
they stay on hold so that my co-host
doesn't sound like a total idiot again
yeah Travis
God [ __ ] dammit [ __ ] [ __ ] there is my
mother what I'm sorry Travis is that
Travis yelling at the staff but his own
issues spilling out sorry I feel bad
yeah that guy just hung up this is why
your mom left
what you gotta relax dude you gotta you
gotta chill out it's okay
empty out the goddamn control room and
find out where this is going on it's
either there or there or out there
somewhere so what is what he's saying is
he went to everybody in the control room
that's working for the show everybody
leave and go out on the hunt for the
hammer
he's also also the control room noise I
think if he says everybody get out no
he's saying every day he's still playing
with the hammer because he doesn't know
if it's coming from below or above or
from the sides so he wants everybody to
get out of the control room and find the
hammer okay get out get out now make it
the woman talking in my ear was talking
about the Labor Day special repeatedly
every time we went to a SOT yeah what do
you mean in the conversation not in the
bush thought no no no this poor girl
this girl he's not yelling at her fine a
lot of control but yeah frumply things
up throwing them out violently he's not
happy with certain writing either but
he's already he's made himself clear
he'll get to that [ __ ] outta control
[ __ ]
I love when people curse and they get
upset and they start cursing I like that
Burress and intimidate people of color
the new sheriff of Maricopa County who
beat Joe Arpaio joins us next okay and
we don't know why I bother to say how to
cut the slots when you don't do it I
just don't I don't know why I just so
now I have to chase those stupid goddamn
entrails that you allowed him to stick
out there Jesus Christ is that a crazy
[ __ ] sound coming in my ears [ __ ]
stupid hammering he's having a rough one
man he's slammed just pen down on this
one Conan O'Brien when he did that yeah
cuz you get to kiss his hair is that a
pledge any bit yeah yeah he's got that
Conan O'Brien bang thing going on but
he's so pissed at everything that's
going on and none of it's lost on
cumulative - yeah it's all happening for
him tonight and he's a morning tunnel
and the terrible horrible no good very
bad day he goes do they even have
newscasts like this in Australia it's a
children's book oh yeah Alexander and
the terrible horrible no good very bad
day
hey he's the entrails are probably
there's something in there there's
certain things in writing when you
reading him a lot of just harder to say
right and for him I don't know what it
what is it what it is but there's
something that he doesn't like the way
it's written these price it can you not
and they just keep writing it like that
right they're like [ __ ] you I don't even
trail is I don't know what that means
somebody probably was like ah Laurence
doesn't like this you know and they're
like yeah well what Lawrence doesn't
like yeah I'll tell you how much I care
about that [ __ ] him yeah no you just
looked up entrails like I understand
that are you trying to be cute I told
you why I wanted those yeah he's trying
to cheeky to quote you like here's what
entrails are Jim by the letter n trail
with this probably the word with that
ends in end d you I'm gonna safely
assume that you and I both know that
entrails are a thing
yes smoke thing yeah I don't know what
it means that what he's so much but in
the context of Lawrence yeah we don't
know either I don't know what that means
we know what they really are
thank you me Anthony
goddamnit can you imagine if Florence
had to work with an ting junkie smile on
his [ __ ] face
not even sincere and what's he gonna do
to make it better bring in another one
of those [ __ ] shoe box cakes yeah
mother cooks like a bunch of logs Thank
You Lyle I'm glad to hear hear
Lyle O'Donnell what's all that laughter
in my ear wild trip person being the
only Stafford that Lawrence O'Donnell's
like take out for you Lyle that's what
he heard in his ear yeah [ __ ] Labor
Day what are you pregnant
there's craziness there's craziness is
my there's trillion jokes in my ear
Yuma Yo Ma we got a fix to be out oh
yeah this is one go back to a couple of
cuz this is when he's like this is his
moment when he's like I'm out here doing
what I'm doing and it [ __ ] say ten
seconds yeah yeah
god damn entrails that you allowed him
to stick out there
Jesus Christ
crazy [ __ ] sound coming in my ear
this [ __ ] stupid hammering I told you
why I wanted those [ __ ] words cut
yeah he's livid just [ __ ] sucks it
[ __ ] sucks to be out here with this
out-of-control [ __ ] feels like a man
every [ __ ] thing can come in on my
ear at any moment that's what I know
anybody and then it into my [ __ ] ear
at any time something some woman talking
about what we're doing after the show
for drinks I mean he sounds like a
lunatic crazy person people just get in
my ears all the time he's completely
right there's not one thing he's done
this made me think he's wrong well he
started throwing all the [ __ ] around I
got it he's on the air and he's asking
about to write something a certain way
and they did it anyway yeah and he's
like what the [ __ ] I lost now it's just
about everything
yeah yeah any complaint that he may have
had last week that now it's a good time
to bring it up right everybody's [ __ ]
with me and there's some lady who's
talking about what bar she's going to
later and she's in my ear right now I
don't understand why she's talking to me
about what she's doing after the show
when I have to do the show yeah he's
just he's just he's right he's right
this is why we're in the shape that
we're in god damn it [ __ ] things
there's a reason these words have to be
cut precisely oh I want to know what
that means
I'm assuming that it means like words
instead that he can say them yeah yeah I
don't know what's words like what what
is it that he did there's a word he
stumble you know I'm tripping big a Q
you can't go s T words right these are
something he's [ __ ] tripping on or
just it's hard for him to say maybe he
didn't do his vocal exercises before he
started yeah how now brown cow how now
brown cow how much is his words are [ __ ]
hammer ear hunt hammer ear the rain in
Spain falls mainly in the plain go [ __ ]
yourself
you [ __ ] there's only uh less than a
minute left
oh and everyone in the audience is gonna
complain about what that guy just said
is absolutely wrong oh boy oh it must
have been like a pre-taped maybe yeah
yeah that [ __ ] up the context of it
all possibly there's our beautiful
intern thank you
how do you say this guy's last night
jesus [ __ ] d-bag Hitler [ __ ]
guests faces coming up in the middle of
a [ __ ] I have two degrees you know
when do I get full-time Laurence thank
you
all right celery boy Lawrence
they really threw him under the goddamn
bus huh they really did they they wanna
show one of those staffers was really
like you know we should [ __ ] with today
lawrence O'Donnell hey Mediaite
what do you think of this video see this
is what's annoying heap I didn't realize
he apologized he did apologize MSNBC
host lawrence O'Donnell apologized
Wednesday for a cursed filter Brant
Carter why he didn't release it
O'Donnell was not on the air but cameras
were rolling as he went ballistic during
a break complaining can't [ __ ] NBC
pas oh call [ __ ] I don't you the [ __ ]
the noise above Abbas the last word host
said he was totally at fault and tweeted
a better anchorman and a better person
would have had a better reaction to
technical difficulties I am sorry you
know how about this a better staff
wouldn't have constantly had that happen
when you were repeatedly asking it to
stop what about the guy with the hammer
I hope he was killed I hope I hope that
they found who that person was and they
fired a nail gun into his temple and
that was it yeah you [ __ ] up King
Lawrence he or she leaves a weapon for
the [ __ ] plastic that's what I hope
happened to that guy
wow you really love lawrence O'Donnell
no I don't care about it I've never
watched his show I probably don't agree
with a lot of his politics I'm gonna
start watching his show just he's
probably a smarmy liberal he's a very
smart man [ __ ] him I don't care if he's
a big dick but I want to start I want to
start watching just in case something
slips through yeah
something good I mean he gets pissed he
is really really pissed I don't know if
it's this Chris what would me and Sam
we're trying to figure out Sam and I
it's right Sam and I correct yes Chris
in Maryland what's going on brother yeah
I was thinking the distance away from
where Lawrence is at they have to keep
the text a certain size that he can read
it so if the text in what he's reading
if the sentences aren't chopped
correctly it might cause him to like
cause certain pauses and incorrect
places it could screw them up a little
bit maybe I don't know it's possible
thank you yeah cause it seemed like you
had a problem with the writing and then
also with the way the clips were cut he
has everything
just [ __ ] it relax bro there's no way
that everything can be wrong right
now you can't you can't be mad at the
entire show nobody's had these issues
he's having the hammering Kwang is 100%
right
this [ __ ] dummies yammering in his
ear he's a hundred percent right and
trying to make if he's asked for
something to be cut a certain way
because it's easier for him on the air
and they're not doing it he's a hundred
percent right I don't even like finding
out that people are making plans for
after the show while the shows on when
they're not in my ear like when I just
see them in the booth
true and I'm they're just socializing
absolutely guys on vacation yeah you're
not supposed to be on me you should be
doing what the audience is doing
fighting boredom no no I mean I thought
they'd be locked in Oh No yeah that was
that's the wrong thing entirely